if art is a reflection of society
then this display of work by filipino
artist toy
imao can be seen as a portrayal of young
people's struggle for academic freedom
in the philippines
tom calls it barricada or barricade he
created it to commemorate the 50th
anniversary of the diliman commune
in february 1971 activists marched
to the university during martial law and
declared it liberated
from state forces the incident ended in
a violent siege
and now similar battle lines are drawn
once again
the military has ended a decades-old
agreement with the university of the
philippines
to keep state forces out of its campuses
across the country
the military says the university has
been a haven of recruitment
for communist rebels the new people's
army and the military have been fighting
for more than 50 years
the conflict is described as the world's
oldest
existing communist insurgency so
how come that they will equate the
obligation of this
contract na militarize naming
no only yop has this kind of agreement
why
what makes yop so special to have this
this kind of
treatment four other universities have
also been accused of encouraging dissent
in a joint statement to the military
their heads say such allegations are
irresponsible and without proof
critics say the military's decision to
cancel its accord with the university of
the philippines
is deeply disturbing it could soon mean
that
soldiers in civilian clothes could join
students in rallies
and that the atmosphere of freedom in
campuses would soon be replaced
by fear university education
which means you need to study the range
of ideas that man has
thought of since time immemorial we have
a
long tradition of heroes fighting for
freedom
if there is fear then learning cannot
happen
across the country student activists are
up in arms too
they're unfairly targeting the youth
sector and it's because we are actually
very critical about the government so
and i think it's actually the duty of
students actually do that
much of tom's work has been focused on
the legacy of the martial law era
when young people were under siege and
turned to art
as a means of expression and defense he
says recent events are a reminder
that those times of trouble and conflict
could be returning
jamal lindogan al-jazeera manila